so
yesterday the name paxton smith was
trending nationwide on social media and
is still trending last i checked
before i figured out who this person is
and why they've become notable i saw
that such luminaries as
hillary clinton once again and sarah
silverman and jessica valenti and a
bunch of people who with pronoun
pronouns in their bio
were extolling her bravery and that was
enough for me to know that whatever
paxton smith did it probably wasn't good
and my instincts were correct here's usa
today with the story it says a high
school valedictorian from texas
flipped the script on school officials
by using her graduation speech
to speak out against the state's newly
signed law banning abortions as early as
six weeks after conception
paxton smith has submitted and entirely
had submitted an entirely different
speech on the effect of the media
uh on young minds to school officials
for the commencement ceremony
at lake highlands high school in dallas
on sunday but smith
said it was important to use the moment
to criticize a controversial abortion
law signed by governor greg abbott last
month
smith called the legislation a war on
the rights of your mothers a war on the
rights of your sisters a war on the
rights of your daughters
we cannot stay silent smith said to the
graduating class smith was able to
finish her speech without interruption
it's not unusual for school officials to
intervene
when a student deviates from an approved
graduation speech the impromptu speech
has prompted the richardson independent
school district to re-evaluate its set
of protocols
regarding future student speeches well
of course
they weren't going to intervene during
this stunt as they would have if her
politics were different
they wouldn't want to be accused of
being agents of the patriarchy or
whatever
now as reluctant as i am to give this
stun any more attention
i do think it's worthwhile to listen to
a portion of the girl's
pro-abortion diatribe because we we can
learn from it
we're not learning the things she wants
us to learn but still i do find it quite
instructive so let's
listen now i have dreams
and hopes and ambitions every girl
graduating today does and we have spent
our entire lives working towards our
future
and without our input and without our
consent
our control over that future has been
stripped away from us
i am terrified that if my contraceptives
fail
i am terrified that if i am raped
then my hopes and aspirations and dreams
and efforts for my future will no longer
matter
i hope that you can feel how
gut-wrenching that is
i hope you can feel how dehumanizing it
is
to have the autonomy over your own body
taken away from you
and i cannot give up this platform
to promote complacency and peace when
there is a war
on my body and a war on my rights
a war on the rights of your mothers a
war
on the rights of your sisters a war on
the rights of your daughters
we cannot stay silent
well that was all a bunch of muddled
garbage
her reasoning is as morally bankrupt as
it is intellectually vacuous none of the
claims she made there were remotely true
but i don't blame her she's just a kid
17 18 years old high school student
um i blame instead the adults in her
life and the cultural and political
forces in our country that have
convinced this young lady that her
dreams and hopes and ambitions
are dependent on her ability to murder
her children
i mean that's what she believes and i
believe that she really believes that
and i i don't really blame her for
believing such hideous nonsense as
it's what she's been conditioned to
believe so let's think about this just
for a moment
um paxton says that her dreams hopes and
ambitions
hinge on her right to dismember any
future babies that she might conceive
she says indeed that her aspirations for
the future
will quote no longer matter if she's not
able to kill a baby after a heartbeat is
detected
she needs to have unfettered unlimited
access to any and all child killing
resources
or else her life is over and all of her
plans for the future are but dust and
ash
now in order to hold this demented point
of view
she must first of all believe that human
life in the womb is totally worthless
she must see pregnancy as a sort of
zero-sum game
either she dehumanizes her child or she
is dehumanized if she's forced to treat
her child as a human
then she's no longer human there's only
so much humanity to go around
she thinks there's only there's only
room for one human between the two of
them
a law that would potentially prevent her
from throwing her own children away like
so much garbage
is a law that deprives her of humanity
that's the way she sees it
and she must also believe that there is
no reliable way to prevent the birth of
a future baby without abortion
she mentions rape but far less than one
percent of all abortions are due to rape
in 99 99 plus percent of cases
babies are conceived through an
intentional act
by mother and father and then they're
killed
because either mother or father or both
decide that they don't want to deal with
the natural results of that intentional
act
now i don't know i'm beginning to see a
way to prevent pregnancy
that works literally 100 percent of the
time
and you don't have to kill anybody third
perhaps most disturbingly
in order to say everything that she just
said
paxton must like likewise believe
that there is no way for a woman to
fulfill her ambitions and chase her
dreams
once she has a baby she equates
motherhood
with death itself once you become a
mother
your goals your purpose your very life
are over
and this is not a straw man of what she
said it is literally what you said
our control over our future has been
stripped away from us she said
my dreams for my future no longer matter
this is the language she's using and
she's being applauded for it
she sees motherhood as the end of all
dreams
the disintegration of hope the crushing
of ambition
it is a dreary miserable
fearful view of of the world and life
and womanhood
and it's exactly what the abortion
industry wants her to believe
exactly like what people like hillary
clinton want her to believe
and tell her to believe and it's
entirely false
little does paxton know but you don't
have to give up
any dreams or any goals when you become
a mother
you might end up changing your goals
because your priorities have changed
and become less centered around yourself
but there's no reason why any particular
ambition must change or be abandoned
it's true that it can be more difficult
more challenging
to do certain things as a parent but
nothing has become
impossible that was possible before
in fact as a parent far from having your
dreams erased
you now have your dreams multiplied you
have
additional hopes and plans for the
future
i would even say greater hopes and plans
your designs for your life have expanded
not shrunk abortion does not preserve
your ability to fulfill your goals you
don't need abortion for that
i mean you're a strong woman right
you're a fighter a go-getter
isn't that what you you would say about
yourself
isn't that what the culture tells you to
believe about yourself
well it does say that and tell you that
but then it also tells you
that you're incapable of achieving your
goals and being a mother at the same
time
so you have to choose one or the other
one thing must die
your child or your dreams
that's what the culture tells you that's
what feminists tell you
it tells you that that you're strong but
then treats you like you're weak
like you need to pay someone a man most
likely to kill your child
just so that you can be happy and
successful in life this is a message of
helplessness
of dependence of fear
and that's what the abortion industry
says to women like paxton
be afraid be very afraid your life is
over if you get pregnant
the only way out is through bloodshed
the only way out is through death and
destruction
it's a lie and the worst thing you know
is to realize what a lie it was only
after it's too late
after you've already made the fateful
choice and you've given up the one thing
you can never get back
your child you don't have to give up
your
career ambitions forever just because
you have a kid
that's something you can still have you
give up your child you can never have
your child back
many women whether they'll say it
publicly or not and many will say it
publicly if only people would listen
have exercised their right to choose
quote unquote
and then lived a little longer and
looked at their lives and realized that
all they have now that's worth having
they still could have had with a child
but the
one thing that was the most worth having
they gave up
forever they killed
the greater dream for the sake of the
lesser one
it was a choice yeah but a false choice
and it can't be undone
that's the path that paxton is already
walking towards
because she's been brainwashed to
believe that her dreams depend on
death and that is a
horrible and so all the people who've
convinced paxton smith of that lie
and so many other young women of that
same lie
are today canceled and to say that
they're canceled i think is is uh
doesn't quite go far enough um
but that's it listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated